Mặc dù đã tích toán để chuốn trải khỏi Việt Nam ngay sọ viên ghiển. Nhưng đúng là không thể chuốn thoát khỏi cường ăn Việt Nam.
Tối ngày 20, người dân tài một khoảng hàng kênh đường liên từ động phần bất hình.
Vô cùng khoảng hàng kỳ chứng kiến, các đối tình kẻ anh rất mất nồng.
Hãy trong đêm 20,000 năm, có mạnh thành phúc chim bên con các cầu biểu của bộ của mình.
Đắt tập trung lực lượng, hấp dụng đồng bộ các biểu sắp hiểu phố, quý sách yếu vất nống.
Bắt dữ được hai thu phạm kí đang lượng trốn tại khu vực giáp bình giới Việt Nam cầu biệt.
Chỉ chưa đầy bấy miệng hai giờ sâu kỳ gian.
Đồng thời, mở động điều tra, bắt dữ tâm đối tượng được việc nằm khác,
vì đã không tối giết hợp phạm, giúp sức cho khoảng hàng lượng trốn của hai thu phạm trên.
Đây là hai đối tình kính là gây ra bù nổ xuống, giết người, tại thành phố chim bên ngay sâu kỳ gian.
Thì các đối tình đã dành trống lượng trốn, đồng thời là phi tàng các quần chứng,
tại các quốc vực khúc tầm nhìn, tôi nhìn mỗi hàng đầu, điều không qua mắt được lượng kinh sách.
Quả quái tình đấu danh, yếu liên tục thay đổi lời khai, nhưng cứ kính tài lếu, kính cứ,
kết đối tình đã thương nhận hành vi phạm đối.
Chỉ chưa đối tình, giải kênh sâu, chim bên xin, viên, với cùng ta fiasi, đã đến thành phố mồ xin mình Việt Nam.
Chỉ dù xuống, để giết người, và tôi là người dục tiếp cộng xuống mặt đời này.
Và hoài hai mũ thẳng năm, phải không phải sâu.
Sau khi người an, tôi đã bị cầu màn Việt Nam mặt dữ.
Tôi nhận thức được hành vi của mình là sạch, và tôi rất hồi ất bây giờ biệt vạm của mình.
Tôi cũng vào vạm được thư để Việt Nam đi mai nật nhất để là Lemaloo, Lorenzo, Tobias và Sau Nisham để giống xuống sát hại.
Mặc dù đã định toàn để chốn trải khỏi Việt Nam ngày sau khi người an.
Nhưng đúng là không thể chốn thóan, khỏi công an Việt Nam.
Mà tôi xin chìu chân nghiệp trên pháp lợi.
Tôi sẽ đối tình, in tên, sẽ đối tình, sẽ đối tình, sẽ đối tình, sẽ đối tình, sẽ đối tình, sẽ đối tình, sẽ đối tình.
Tôi sẽ đối tình, sẽ đối tình, sẽ đối tình.
Chỉ đạo của anh, lẫn đạo bộ công an, đặc yêu cầu rất cao với công an thành phố chimın, phải khấn cứu ngầm đó đồng cơ ghê an.
Trí sẽ quang bỏ đối tình li quang và ngôn có phù kỹ xuy động.
Điệt.
Vì anh, chống bắt giữ không thủ người xam ơn, không thể dành các an.
Thế hình tin đầu, bãnh lĩnh, xử mua dí, dúng cảm của lực lượng phối học của công an thành phố và các cùp hiểu của công an.
Là lời cảnh báo với những rối tường mắt đầu, có thường pháp lục gây mất an nân cật tử tại Việt Nam, chắc kán sẽ bây giờ liên nghi Minh.